hello everyone after showing you that
game where Vladimirovich is defeated
Bobby Fischer in the French defense in
1970 in the tournament of Peace in
ravine I also told you that a lot of
people consider this to be a kawatche of
its immortal game but he himself does
not he thinks this is his not immortal
game he doesn't like to call that he
calls it his best game that he ever
played it was played in 1973 so three
years after that game against Bobby
Fischer was played in Benghazi in
Croatia and I don't think you can find
it this game anywhere online I mean I
had to dig it out in Croatian chess
forum so it's definitely definitely a
complicated game and he's playing
against me land Mutulu which milan
Mottola which was somewhere maybe second
or third strongest grandmaster in
Yugoslavia probably third behind the
settler gligar rich and the borislav Eve
cook but definitely a strong player and
I did read some some funny things about
him for example he if he had a lost
position he didn't resign the game he
would prefer to wait for the game to be
adjourned so it would read in the
newspapers that he he returned the game
that he didn't lose and also I read this
might or might not be true that he lost
a game against mark diamond of on
purpose he resigned for a bribe of $400
and that this was the game that allowed
mark time enough to qualify for the
candidates but if this is true then his
result against Bobby Fischer where
Fischer destroyed him six to zero does
kind of feel like justice since you know
throwing getting into the candidates by
by winning a game that was resigned you
know on purpose is pretty much a crime
against chess and I think this happened
I'm just saying if it did but okay since
the one miracle watch which himself
considers this to be the best game he
ever played let's see this beauty
kabocha which has the white pieces and
plays
Knight to f3 we have g6 so so far we
have already opening and now he plays
efore so basically pretty much the same
as if he played efore black responded
with g6 and then white continued would
Knight to f3 d6 and we have Bishop to c4
Knight to c6
now d4 Knight to f6 Queen to e2
protecting the e4 pawn Bishop to g4 and
c3 protecting the d4 pawn as Bishop
captures on f3 was a threat after the
Queen captures Knight would capture the
pawn on d4 d5 and now Bishop to b5
pinning the night so Knight can't help
out with the tension in the center
Knight to d7 and here we have a very
interesting move that that already has a
little bit poison to it watch which
plays d5 and Mottola which responds with
Knight to b8 and this is very
interesting because if he play the
knight to e7 then kawatche which has
this interesting option of winning a
pawn with Knight captures on e5 if you
recapture the night then Queen captures
Bishop always well and if black captures
the Queen then Bishop captures on d7
would check the King has nowhere to go
so Queen has to capture and after Knight
captures and something like Bishop b3
Knight to f6 check King to d8 and f3
white wanna pawn and we'll have a you
know a perfectly fine game so instead
after d5 Knight stabile it was played h3
and now black can't really retreat with
the bishop if you go h5 or getting g4 so
he has the capture denied they should
captures Queen captures and already this
is a small victory before Camacho HS you
know does have the bishop pair Bishop to
e7 and here we have g3 and g3 is a very
powerful move if you decide to play
something like Bishop to h6 which seems
perfectly reasonable you know not
allowing like the castle you're getting
Bishop to g5 and you have to exchange
bishops and this only helps black and
even if you don't go for
like Bishop to h6 even if you Castle
again Bishop to g5 is coming so g3 a
move that is ready to meet Bishop to g5
but you'll see it in the game Bishop to
g5 was played but now this is met with
Knight 2 D 2 and since the point is in G
3 H 4 is is coming so H 5 H 4 basic to
h6 and now Knight to f1 now offering to
exchange the bishops as the white did
improve his position the night is rate
the jump to e3 and black did lose a
couple of temples with that Bishop so
Bishop captures rook captures and a6
Bishop to a4 and now Mutulu which plays
King to f8 it's definitely an
interesting move probably even a good
one because if you if you decide to
Castle here I mean this is probably okay
if you're an angel
but if you're a human you do have to put
your king in the line of fire
for example castles g4 immediately H
capture screen captures and after Knight
to f6 Queen to g1 but you know you know
you don't want to do this if you're
human
for example night and night g3 is coming
h5 is coming it could be unpleasant
so after Bishop f4 a for King to f8 now
I'm pinning night the e3 Knight to f6
stopping temporarily debt upon pawn to
g4 move quattro H castles Knight B to d7
we have before preventing the knight
from entering the position with night to
c5 from c5 the night would be able to
jump either to d3 you know to put
pressure on e4 would be unpleasant for
white came to g7 and 83 now and black
immediately pushes a5 he wants to break
out break up this nice pawn chain white
created on the Queen side
rook to a-1 Queen to e7 developing the
Queen and also connecting rooks Bishop
to b3 nice to be six now and see for a
capture some b4 hCAP a capture some
before and now mythology decides to
exchange both pair of rooks
recaptures anyone root characters anyone
and now rook to a8 rook captures an a8
Knight captures an a8 and we have Bishop
to c2 and here
Mutulu which probably should have gone
for something like c6 you definitely
want to do something about this nice
pawn chain wide created and the c6 would
definitely be the way to go but instead
he he chose a more active approach he
played b5 sacrificed the pawn but you
know after seek after some b5 that was
played in the game
Queen to e8 now attacking the b5 pawn
Bishop to d3 defending nice to b6 and
now these pawns will be a permanent
target Queen to d1 what was white
White's idea here White's idea here is
okay he does have a doubled beep on but
this b5 and d5 pawns are beautiful
locating to this backward c7 pawn can
never move forward and this makes it
also a permanent target
so what White's plan is clear he wants
to harass the c7 point Queen to d1
preparing Queen to c1 Queen to a8 and
now the powerful Queen to see one move
and this Queen to see one move is
extremely powerful it threatens c7 it
eyes the h6 Square which if this Knight
moves this after g4 and this night after
it moves from e3 that h6 Square will be
deadly and also it it allows the Queen
to jump to g5 but you'll see what I mean
by this he is now attacking the c7 pawn
sorry too many red squares he's now
attacking the c7 point you can defend
the c7 point either by playing Knights
to e8 or by playing Queen to be 7 or a
queen to be 8 or something but the thing
is black must play Knight to e8 and this
is what Kawachi which saw if black plays
something like Queen to b7 to defend
this then Knight to f5 move is
completely winning for white if you move
the King for example King somewhere
you're getting the queen is coming to h6
if you capture another night
then we will capture knight on f6 and
white will gobble up all the pawns on
the Kings side completely winning for
white so after this
Knight to a5 move even if you capture it
again Queen to g5 check now King goes to
f8 for example Queen captures on f6 and
after something like F captures on e4
Queen d8 check King g7 Bishop captures
again are completely winning position
for white again Queen g5 is coming
you're losing the h5 pawn or even
something like Bishop f3 to capture h5
and then threatened the f7 pawn a very
uncomfortable position for black so
after this powerful Queen to see one
move black of course played Knights to
e8 so defending properly now Knight to
f5 isn't really doing anything since
after Queen to g5 check you can't
capture the Knight g4 now since the
knight is no longer protecting the g4
square H captures Knight captures and
now the idea of Queen to h6 is here and
you can't really stop this black plays
Queen to d8 Queen to h6 would check King
to g8 and Bishop to e2 we have Queen to
e7 h5 now g5 of course not allowing
white to break open the the pawn
structure and the bishop to f1 Queen to
d8 King to H 2 and we have Queen to e7
black doesn't really have anything to do
here you can't move the knight anywhere
you don't you don't want to move it to
g7 or Knight to f6 is coming the Queen
can't move she has to keep keep an eye
on this f6 Square and it does seem like
a good idea since this Knight and b6
isn't really doing anything to get this
Knight into the game but this would be
actually losing for black you black
tried something like Knight to d6 then
this beautiful beautiful idea of b6 is
coming sacrificing a pawn and making
this B 5 square available for the bishop
and after you capture a Bishop to b5 and
this is completely winning for white if
you play something like Queen to e7 your
getting bishop capture 77 after Queen
captures you're losing the g5 pawn the
h5 t h5 1 is coming up the board and
it's completely winning for white so
after King h2 black doesn't really have
anything to do here by the way he played
King to e7 King the g3 Kawachi which is
improving the position of asking before
he makes his intentions clear Queen back
to the 8th now f3 Queen to e7 and now
Bishop to h3 came back to d8 and now
Knight to e3
now this Knight was protecting f6 it no
longer does but he's preparing to play
Knight to f5 so Queen to f6 as the f6
square is now available Knight to f5 we
have night the c4 Bishop back to f1 the
knight has to go back Knight to be 6 and
now kink to g4 and White's position has
improved immensely Queen captures on h6
Knight captures on h6 would check King
to g7 Knight back to a5 with check King
to f6 and night to e3 and this is a this
is a complete truth one for black it's
very hard to play a move here for black
you can't move the King or you're losing
the g5 pawn this Knight can't move
because of the same tactic if this
Knight moves b6 is coming immediately
and making room for the bishop and b5
and if you try something like Knight to
g7 then you get h6 Knight has to go back
king h5 King to e7 Knight to f5 check
King f8 now h7 is coming and you can't
stop the promotion you have to give up
the piece for example not to have 6
check King h6 and now you have to
capture and you're down a piece and
losing the game so after night to e3
black is unfortunately forced to play
the move we already discussed Knight to
c8 and Kawachi which immediately plays
it this is the move that that allows the
whites to go for the win b6 c captures
and Bishop to b5
the that night pair is actually a
terrible night pair as none of the
night's can enter the game night to see
seven attacking the bishop bishop goes
to d7 now attacking the knight on c8
Knight to e7 and b5 and those Knights
aren't going anywhere
Knight the g8 we have Knight to f5 nice
to a it was played and Bishop to eh now
by Kawachi which even though he can
capture this pawn immediately he decides
not to because after Knight captures you
get you have to calculate night to h6
check King has to go back and after King
g7 he will be attacking both of your
pieces and now we have to calculate that
Knight to f5 with check is actually
winning for white after King captures
Knight will capture on h6 and the H
point is too powerful the H point is
unstoppable Harry is unstoppable
so after Knight wait he doesn't want to
give him a touch any chances he first
plays Bishop - I ate now after Knight
captures and e6 he will have the option
of capturing the pawn with Bishop f7 and
Bishop captures night and g8 tonight -
c7 was played attacking the bishop now
Bishop God comes to c6 nights the e6 and
now you have to give up the pawn Knight
yeah sorry
a knight to e6 was played but you don't
really have any other move to play here
Knight is threatening to capture and b6
this can't be stopped
you don't really have any other moves
this Knight can't move the bishop is
guarding both both squares where the
knight can jump so Mottola which tried
night to e6 and after D captures an e6
King F captures on e6 Knight captures on
d6 now if you play Knight to f6 check ok
he does push the King back 1 square
I came to e7 Knight to c8 check kinked
d8 and Knight captures and b6 and in
this position Mottola which resigned the
game so definitely a beautiful game and
a very complicated game as black didn't
really make any mistakes
white just played
the strongest moves at all times so
that's that's a very cool of a lot of
kawatche which you know he beats Fischer
but he doesn't consider that to be his
best game I mean okay the only reason
people considered his immortal game is
because he defeated Fischer but actually
Mutulu which also defeated Fischer in
1958 they play sorry in 1968 I believe
they played a training match of four
games and my polish managed to win one
game against Fischer but it wasn't an
official match or anything it was just a
training match so I am here two players
who have defeated Fischer battle it out
and kolache which emerges the victor so
does the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to think puts a read for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
soon